foreign
everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today is scp-84
object class Euclid
special containment procedures
scp-84 is currently under a full
non-interaction order until the full
extent of the emission waves has been
evaluated for detailed documentation on
General fni Orders see document xrg 1182
for detailed documentation on fni orders
in relation to scp-84 see document xrg
1208 a
a continuous surveillance watch is to be
maintained around the active area of
scp-84 with the primary objective of
Civilian misdirection and external
surveillance with no major roads Trails
or other travel routes nearby any
civilians encountered approaching scp-84
are to be deemed suspect and detained
for evaluation under no circumstances
are any foundation or civilian Personnel
allowed into the active area of scp-84
except with Express vocal and written
permission of no fewer than two members
of o5 command
centuries are to maintain their posted
position with line of sight contact
checks on fellow sentries in conjunction
with compass and landmark checking all
reference points should be well outside
the active area of scp-84 should any
Sentry found to report in Via vocal roll
call full recall orders will be issued
to all centuries and containment will be
re-evaluated by Special Response teams
in the event of active area fluctuation
full recall orders are to be assumed by
all active centuries followed by
appropriate action
no form of radio GPS television cell
phone video camera still picture camera
or any other recording or Electronic
media devices are permitted within 100
meters of the active area around scp-84
civilians found with such devices within
this area are to have said devices
confiscated and destroyed immediately
any recordings collected
description
scp-84 appears to be a large radio tower
positioned in the center of a large open
field with two small outbuildings direct
observation and Sample collection from
scp-84 is impossible due to the effect
that is emitted around or from scp-84
scp-84 appears to emit a form of wave or
radiation that has a detrimental effect
on local space-time or reality the most
pronounced aspect of this is the
alteration of local space-time within
the active area of scp-84 externally the
active area forms a rough Dome shape of
200 meters in diameter scp-84 appears
inside this area at random points
appearing to jump at random times
sometimes even appearing in multiple
locations at once inside the active area
internally the space appears to be
unlimited with scp-84 at the center
scp-84 is impossible to reach due to the
emitted effect attempts to approach
scp-84 within the active area have
returned the observation that scp-84
retains its relative position on the
horizon even after three months and 12
days of dedicated Direct Travel both by
vehicle and on foot termination tests
have proved impossible has no means of
Destruction are capable of physically
reaching scp-84 even when entered from
outside the active area local space will
also distort periodically this will
cause relative distances to randomly
extend or contract in a flicker causing
buildings or objects to suddenly jump
thousands of meters away or Rush up to
other points sometimes even causing
overlaps these overlaps have a markedly
detrimental effect on living tissue
the town of is assumed to have been
situated in or around the original
manifestation of the active area this
town is no longer observable from
outside the active area appearing only
once inside the active area
has maintained the same population
343 humans for the duration of its
encapsulation births appear to be
impossible along with normal aging
patterns
and or homicide appears to be
circumvented by the area of effect with
dead subjects flickering and appearing
alive and unharmed several seconds after
death there are also reports of events
rewinding causing things like Mortal
wounds to visibly freeze and close
subjects appear to exhibit many events
of inconsistent space-time as do most
structures for detailed observations
c-log 84 A4
electronic devices and recording
equipment do not function correctly in
or around the active area subjects
report bizarre or unsettling
Transmissions from video and audio
recording and Playback devices this acts
to tonally isolate from the outside
world precluding any need for foundation
enacted containment it also appears
impossible to leave the active area
after a random period of time one
subject from found on the grass plane
c-log 84a4 reported he had been
traveling for six years he was found
approximately 400 meters from city
limits
log 84 A4
record of observed anomalous events
relating to scp-84
to be made of 110 meter by 10 meter
section of grass repeated endlessly to
make up the plane sections appear to be
randomly rotated as they are formed
causing sections of grass and small
ground variations to line up incorrectly
few non-human organisms appear to exist
within the active area those outside the
active area avoid it and appear to
vanish shortly after entering animals
observed inside the active area appear
normal but behave strangely shuddering
movements sudden shivering repetitive
loops and other abnormal actions appear
to indicate these may not be actual
animals animals appear to Flicker and
vanish after three to four hours
vocal communication is difficult within
the active area vocal communication
appears normal within five meters of the
speaking subject with reports of a
slightly muffled quality reported
commonly outside of five meters subjects
appear to be speaking from a great
distance with a great deal of echoing
reports of speech being heard several
after this subject to stop speaking and
speech occurring with no subject
speaking are also not uncommon
detailed observation of the radio tower
is impossible due to the inability to
physically reach it and the effect of
the broadcast on most observational
equipment basic telescope or binocular
systems show the tower to be hazy and
static fault while more Advanced
Equipment is subject to the anolis
broadcast effect
weather patterns as well as basic day
night cycles appear to be totally random
overhead Sky will randomly cycle between
day night clear and other weather
patterns relative sun and Cloud position
appear random as well with frequent
flickering and blurring between
different states
physical alteration or damage to
anything within the active area is
impossible actions such as digging
Demolition and new constructions will
suddenly blur and be reset to their
previous unaltered state at random
points subjects inside a reset structure
such as inside a hole will become
instantly trapped and fused
humans in the active area around scp-84
exhibit some of the more striking and
easily observed reality Distortion
effect these include
sudden blurring of limbs or head
appearing to suddenly gyrate at
violently high speeds for several
seconds before ending subjects
experience no pain and are often unaware
of this phenomenon
looping typically manifested as the
repeating of 8 to 20 seconds of time
subjects will go through an action for
example exiting a doorway picking up an
article of clothing then suddenly freeze
and flicker then return to the original
starting position of the loop and repeat
the action even if this involves a
sudden teleportation of significant
distance rarely subjects appear to
become caught in a permanent Loop
observation and interrogation of
subjects and show that basic human needs
such as food water and sleep are no
longer required after prolonged exposure
to the active area some subjects report
not having eaten or drank for they
believe five years one elderly subject
also reports having made
2110 unsuccessful attempts
subjects will sometimes be able to pass
through solid matter without incident
these periods appear to last for random
periods of time and begin and end
without warning subjects inside solid
matter when the period ends will become
trapped or fused until the period
resumes one subject reports being
trapped below the waist in a wall for
two years
extreme psychological distress is
observed after long-term exposure the
Transmissions barrier which is
compromised over long-term exposure
subjects in advance to reception States
typically reset after several months
recorded Transmissions show a slight
Cycles overall attempting to catalog and
record these broadcasts has therefore
been remanded to autonomous systems to
preclude any additional loss of
foundation personnel
and log
okay I think that about does it for
today
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Big sip
zargaron
oh crop guy
James Samba
braided Peach
fire of prime
Dr Wolf 13.
copster
worthy fire
zazapan
Irish wristwatch
signor
a la trayon
your local Foundation agent
and Lost Boy
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you